yo welcome to this video playing
whiplash so something else be three
let's see III and they succeeded an
interesting way to play I'm going for F
for this kind of bird bird style so how
to play now or probably ninety five
years okay he allows me to make a small
structure a little bit weak so why not
what surprised about that no that looks
quite nice for white so what about this
can you go for c4 not at the moment so
I'm going going to aim 45
let's gain space on Bishop f6 I'm going
to play you 45 just gain space they also
have c4 possibly coming up yes it's
quite nice it's a nice position okay
that was Wonder ender anyway yeah
interesting i can take or i can play you
5 mm it's not so clear what's better
okay let's grab that Spade and keep more
space and keep more pieces on the board
okay well he can take their on b3 I
don't mind it that much you move chicks
is not so bad but context is fine he
still has that double ponder in the end
game I'm slightly better not not really
anything substantial but a bit so mmm
okay maybe just take it to check go here
for Queen a one
check okay so here just allow us the
same game it's not terrible for it but
this is ok I like to play that position
going to try to notice that small
advantage and see how to do it each
region for probably somewhat it seemed
how to do that can I aim for for a 4
here attacking c5 maybe that's an idea
also f5 is a possible idea
maybe going around with the King there
to a forum don't know i'm not quite sure
how to play it so okay
let's see here we get it to a three here
maybe he wants to play the n97 b6 check
okay now that that I should not allow so
let's go back now it be six in itself is
no problem going back simply
yeah with good play verb like this is
equal it's not much to do but still with
this little space advantage i wonder if
i can play hope ship h4 I wonder about
that but the iesg five then that sets
the problem
okay maybe I can tempt into Bishop 85 no
I cannot but I have before now is before
i move before deform I don't know what I
interesting let's do it I'm not sure
about this but
really unsure if that helped me or not
so Jack 95's idea is 1 94 95 he can
still go back maybe start with this time
morning if I go d4 Knight if for takes
text King be talking a 7 i'm winning the
pond so he has to go back don't think
that night a for so makes much sense
check ok still plated i-93 is got ok
hmm f6
check ah maybe I simply have wanted to
be too much [ __ ] out of this position
don't get anywhere layer check check
game grab give me increment please and
I've even winning this game which is
kind of strange guy try to try too hard
here this is certainly certainly not so
great you know white was a little bit
better in the same game but it's it's
not much it's really not much maybe that
before idea wasn't good yeah I'm
enjoying just enjoying a little bit of
space and slightly better structure but
it's probably it's just the draw yeah I
was surprised that he actually went for
this ok this is j.r this is stronger
yeah of course nice takes is just stupid
that loses suits one and here i can play
this chap that's actually really nice
that's very nice yeah that is a clear
advantage for watch yeah huge space
advantage but i'm coming up
coming up with the king and this is a
weakness that's very nice for one so
that is what I missed I really had some
doubts about his setup but I can still
play before but now he has the check
that's a huge difference check get here
I still thought something but probably
not check check so check instead of
checking me checking that loses actually
wow wow this wins so and I don't I don't
check have a move now check check King
see for Windsor well I had no time so g
five wins okay that's not really
relevant I had no time and was actually
glad that I could secure the draw by am
taking away all of his pawns who okay
well thanks for watching